We've used cube maps for skyboxes and environment maps for sharp and glossy
reflections and for refraction. It turns out we can even use this same
mechanism for diffuse lighting. For these previous techniques we needed the
direction to the eye and the shading normal in order to compute a reflection or
a refraction ray. For the diffuse component, we just need the shading normal.
Remember, the diffuse component doesn't depend on the eye's direction. We used
the dot product between the normal and the light source vectors when we
computed the effect of a single light on the surface, using Lambert's Law. Now
think big. For a particular point on a surface, consider every texel in our
environment map as a source of light, emitted or reflected. Take the dot
product of the direction vector to each texel from the surface and compute the
dot product with the surface normal. Add these all up. You now have the
contribution of the entire environment map on a single location. You might
think doing this is a bit expensive to do for every pixel we want to
illuminate, and you'd be right. Doing this properly is a good task for path
tracing. However, there are a few things working in our favor. First, once
you've computed the sum of all the contributions of all the texels for one
point on one surface, you've actually computed it for all points with the same
normal direction. Remember that the environment map is infinitely far away, so
what's true for one surface normal is true for them all. The other element
working in our favor is that a cube map can be used to store the results of our
computations. After we compute the sum of all the contributions for a given
normal, we then simply store this value directly at that location, in the cube
map texture. This texture is called the diffuse environment map, or irradiance
map. Now when we want to sum total lighting for the surrounding environment for
a given normal, we can just look it up on the cube map. One other advantage
that we have is that the diffuse map can be quite low resolution while this
original sharp environment map had cube faces that were 512 by 512 texels and
our gloss map was 128 squared. The diffuse map is only usable at only 32 by 32
texels. Nonetheless, it can be expensive to compute the diffuse map, so what we
do is the same as for the glossy map. We compute the texture in advance with
some image processing software. This gives us the texture we need to light the
scene. During rendering, we just use the shading normal to find the overall
contribution of the environment's lighting to the surface fragment.